Đó bù trường bù xí dừng yêu cầu các vẻ phương bù chỉ ngay 1 bốn ngất xác vẻ phương
quyết đất xa đốc bù hạt tần, không dùng quyết trình yêu tiên,
đơn giản hóa thủ tu cành trình để khai công ít nhất bù dự án
bằng bốn gần xác ngay trong thằng sau nâng ngày yì thủ trạm hiểu sấu,
khẩn trương thành lập, kịch toàn và đưa vào vận hành có nhiều quả
quyết phát trình nhờ của điều phương từ các vệnh thu thập vi đình.
Như gồn hai bì bình xam đất nhờ sã hội từ cán sửa an thương mại,
nè đô tương xe dừng hoặc bù lại nhờ,
để cho tuy trong quy ba, nâng ngày thủ trạm hiểu sấu,
bù xí dừng cũng yêu cầu các vẻ phương trình khai các sự an nhờ,
cho tuy có quy mô lớn trong quy ba, quy bốn năm nay.
Cho có diện buộc người tử hiểu phương,
bù xí dừng để gì các đẹp phương tổ chức điều chá,
đánh giá khi lướng thực chất tru cầu thuy nhà của tương gó bứt dần trí để bàn.
Thưa đó, xí dừng kế hoạc đồng tư xe dừng thật,
người dân được thường thật, chánh được lịch phát cung cầu,
về lạm viễn một lực,
lập kế hoạc phát chình nhờ cho tuy nát hành gình cũng trai mi sấu và xe đạn,
ra gình cũng trai mi sấu tới hai gình cũng trai bám quay,
bao gồm buộc tiêu tượng năm,
giái một dự án, lâu trình và một lực quy đau,
người mộ xí dừng để tổ hợp báo cảo tụ tướng trong thành sấu,
để thúc đầy phát chình nhờ cho tuy,
bộ xí dừng cũng đẹg gì các đẹp phương hỗ trợ người dân xe nhờ,
để cho tuy tại các đủ tị lớn.
Theo đó, các đẹp phương cần nghen kiểu,
người trẻ hỗ trợ hướng dẫn tiêu tình kiểu thuật,
an toàn phòng trảy trước trảy lối quy hôn xa đình,
gái tên thóc xa xe dừng nhờ dương, lẹn dầu tâm,
nhiều các hỗ để cho tuy.